despite saudi arabia's murder of jamal
khashoggi president Trump says he won't
be turning against the country yesterday
the president was blunt about his
reasoning being friendly with the Saudis
is in the interests of the US economy
I'm not going to tell a country that's
spending hundreds of billions of dollars
and has helped me do one thing very
importantly keep oil prices down so that
they're not going to a hundred and 150
dollars a barrel right now we have oil
prices in great shape
I'm not going to destroy the world
economy and I'm not going to destroy the
economy for our country by being foolish
with Saudi Arabia the president
continued down that pub today tweeting
quote oil prices getting lower great
like a big tax cut for America in the
world enjoy fifty four dollars was just
eighty two dollars thank you to Saudi
Arabia but let's go lower
Nigel Faraj is a former leader of the UK
Independence Party and the driving force
behind brexit he joins us from London
Nigel the Saudis even though the highest
level of leadership in the country was
implicated in this murder a Peter have
gotten away with it as far as the world
is concerned yeah that's right I mean
look I do understand that for both the
USA and the UK Saudi Arabia's a very
important market to us hundreds of
thousands of jobs linked with selling
aeroplanes and munitions I also get
these strategic alliance with Saudi
Arabia against Iran you know who've been
trying to spread a very extreme form of
Islamism right across the region so I
understand the reasons for it but
imagine if any other country had behaved
like this imagine if Russia had behaved
like this there'd be a much bigger
international outcry and my real problem
mark is that in the wake of the Syrian
crisis sallie Saudi Arabia did not take
a single refugee or displaced person but
we're happy to fund the building of 200
mosques in Germany at what we have seen
what we have seen is Wahhabi ISM being
spread
using Saudi money so fine let's go on
doing trade let's go on having strategic
alliances but let's not be frightened to
be critical of some of the things that
Saudi Arabia does yeah
Saudi Arabia's principle export isn't
oil it's actually ideology and the oil
just enables them to spread that
ideology around the world but basically
15 Saudis killed 3,000 Americans on 9/11
nothing really
President Bush assured us the Saudis are
our friends we now have a crown prince
who Senator Lindsey Graham and others
say is patently unstable and like in
your own royal house you're just a
couple of miles from the courtesan
james's they don't have strict
primogeniture in the House of Saud so
why can't we at least put pressure on
Saudi Arabia to remove this guy as crown
prince and have someone else as Crown
Prince well yes I mean you know MBS as
he's known was sold to us as being this
great reformer the truth is that would
appear not to be the case at all and one
of the things that he does appear to
have done is to pursue the very
unpleasant war that is going on in Yemen
and maybe for a moment we should think
that some of the bombs that we're
selling to Saudi Arabia are actually
being used by him in this war so you're
quite right there are many other options
for who effectively can be the head of
Saudi Arabia you know I understand what
Trump's saying I understand in this
country mrs. Mays reluctance to be too
critical but we should be saying and
doing more and and we should also be
clear to that Khashoggi is being
presented as a sort of hero of
journalism he's probably gonna be Time
Magazine's Man of the Year just because
he is a dead so-called journalist but in
fact he was kind of a deep state Saudi
spook who just happened to fall out with
the royal family in a sense it's it's
it's different sets of bad guys we're
arguing about of course it is but don't
you think actually the truth is all
through the Middle East whether we look
at Iraq or Libya or Sarah
we keep on playing this game of saying
who are the good guys and who are the
bad guys and more often than not we tend
to get it wrong it's it's the old CIA
line he may be an sob but he's our sob
it's actually the truth is the other he
may be our sob but he's still an sob
Nigel thank you and Happy Thanksgiving I
know they don't have it over there but
have a have a turkey on us to celebrate
it thank you